Wouldn’t it be weird if one day in the future
you were buying a home and the listing said,
“batteries not included?”
Yeah well, that could totally happen.
Hey there people, Julian here for DNews.
Electricity is pretty great.
It powers my toaster, my fridge, my hairdryer,
my clothes dryer, my air conditioner, my humidifier,
my dehumidifier, and my pc I use to watch
science youtube videos.
I think I’m gonna keep using it.
The problem is, everyone in all the other
houses feels the same way, usually at about
the same times of day, and they’re driving
the cost of those tasty kilowatts up in the
evening.
Of course during the day if you don’t want
to use power from the grid, you could get
some solar panels and harvest sunlight, but
that’s not helpful when the sun’s down,
also known as nighttime, also known as the
time I need to have electricity to turn lights
on to not bang my shins on all the furniture.
Enter the battery powered home.
The idea is a rechargeable battery stores
energy from solar panels during the day or
from off-peak hours when grid energy is cheapest,
and uses that energy during the rest of the
day.
The problem is if you’ve ever bought batteries
you know they cost approximately one arm and/or
one leg.
Elon Musk thought that was a silly hangup
for what is otherwise a great idea and decided
to do something about it.
Elon Musk, for y’all that don’t know,
is basically what would happen if Tony Stark
lost the goatee.
His interests range from online money movement
to commercial space flight to, most importantly
for this topic, electric cars.
His company Tesla Motors has been refining
electric car batteries for years, engineering
them to be lighter, longer lasting, and more
efficient.
Why don’t we take all those batteries, and
put them on a wall?
So they did that.
The Tesla Power wall Is basically a bunch
of lithium ion cells in a sleek case.
They’re compartmentalized and liquid cooled
to solve the knotty problem of overheating
and burning your house down, something that
is generally undesirable.
If you wanted it as your main power supply
there’s a model that can store and discharge
up to 7 kWh daily and costs $3000.
Best of all it should last 10 years, which
is approximately 8 years longer than my laptop
battery made it before it wouldn’t hold
a charge anymore.
The trick to this longevity is how much power
it outputs.
It’s only pumping out 2 kW continuously
and peak output is 3.3 kW.
The problem that then arises is some appliances
will use more than that output.
An electric clothes dryer could draw that
much power on its own.
So if you want dry clothes, I hope you weren’t
planning on using a microwave too.
If you wanted to be not reliant on the grid
at all, you’d probably need a few powerwalls
to go with your solar roof panels.
Depending on where you live, your power consumption
can vary widely, but the average US home in
2011 used 940 kWh per month.
A solar setup of that size would cost over
$11,000, not including installation or taking
tax credits into account.
Then you’d need 5 Powerwalls to store all
of that sunshine juice, so that’s another
15 grand.
It’s an expensive prospect right now, but
as the cost of batteries and solar panels
continue to drop, individual homes that are
independently powered could become a great
way to kick our fossil fuel habit.
Inexpensive home batteries are looking like
a promising innovation.
They’re not the only company innovating.
Intel creates the breakthrough technologies
that make amazing experiences possible.
Having Intel inside makes for better experiences
outside.
Intel drives innovation with products like
processors, wearables and IOT devices, and
within data centers.
In the PC and beyond.
Going green sounds like a lot of effort.
Is it really worth it?
Trace explains why yes, totally, it is, right
here.
Would you use the powerwall?
Would it be a supplement for your energy use
or would you go all out and be energy independent?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe, and
I’ll see you next time on DNews.